ich freue mich dass sie mit dabei sind
in unserem corona kompakt heute da geht
es vor allem ums geld und alles was
gerade damit zusammenhängen probleme bei
mietzahlungen zum beispiel oder mit
welchen tricks online-betrüger die krone
angst zu abzocke nutzen
außerdem beantwortet hermann josef
tenhagen der chefredakteur von
finanztest ihre fragen und ums geld
zunächst aber einige meldungen vom
heutigen mittwoch
mechernich in nordrhein westfalen
hier geht das rote kreuz ganz
ungewöhnliche wege in einem ehemaligen
schnellimbiss werden jetzt corona tests
gemacht
thomas heinen koordiniert die arbeiten
das war hier die letzte absperrung
ziehen können bis vorne auf die ecke
damit man eine saubere linie haben wo
die autos her fahren
das fastfood-restaurant stand längere
zeit leer
der pächter hat es dem roten kreuz
mietfrei zur verfügung gestellt statt
burger und pommes bekommen patienten mit
corona verdacht jetzt am drive in
schalter ein teströhrchen für den
abstrich dass man einfach geschützt für
die und auch ein selber falls man es ja
gar nicht hat zum beispiel machen kann
und beim hausarzt wäre ja ganz anders
gefährdet gegebenenfalls in der praxis
kreativität ist alles in der korona
krise so auch in diesem sex shop auf der
hamburger reeperbahn
neben windows und kondom ist hier ein
kleiner supermarkt entstanden sein
besitzer benedikt pliquett versucht so
das lahmende erotikgeschäft wieder mit
neuem leben zu füllen
kaufen
jetzt auch schreibwaren oder lampen und
andere ganz klassisch halt die artikel
was ist breit gemischt es häufig so dass
die kunden dann auch sag ich mal das
robot war was hauptsächlich hier drin
war jetzt die letzten jahre
dann müssen mit den bedarf artikeln des
täglichen lebens frankfurt flughafen die
rückholaktion des auswärtigen amtes
läuft weiter gerade kommen urlauber aus
bali zurück man hat schon gemerkt dass
auf die lebensmittel dort teurer werden
und so und dass die leute auch
ängstlicher werden auch touristen
gegenüber an jetzt ist also out of
marley ziemlich viel dich schon von mir
haben noch den nächsten flug
inzwischen meldet die johns hopkins
universität 73.200 17 infizierte in
deutschland 16.100 menschen sind wieder
gesucht manchmal sind es kleine aktionen
die mut machen sollen
die polizei in frankfurt fährt streife
und legt musik auf den lautsprecher
circle of life von elton john
[Musik]
auf twitter schreibt die polizei danke
für lob und zuspruch das tut gut das
gibt kraft und auch die meisten user
finden die aktion klasse
ihr seid schon prast beim nächsten mal
bitte was zum tanzen mambo number five
der könig der löwen mitten in frankfurt
vielen dank für euren einsatz schreibt
ein anderer und grüßt die polizei im
ganzen land tolle aktion auf jeden fall
welche wirtschaftlichen folgen die kuba
krise mit sich bringt darüber spreche
ich jetzt mit unserem heutigen experten
hermann josef tenhagen chefredakteur von
finanztest hallo herr ten hagen guten
tag
wie schätzen sie das ein als fachmann
wie lange kann die bundesrepublik die
wirtschaftlichen ausfälle der krone ab
anämie finanzieren also ein paar monate
geht schon wir haben in den letzten
jahren ja ordentlich gespart
das heißt wir müssen uns erst mal keine
allzu große sorgen machen abzüglich
einer probleme die schon da sind
genau wir haben genug andere probleme
die wir jetzt lösen müssen aber das
problem ist nicht unmittelbar da da
sollten wir uns jetzt erst mal keine
sorgen darum machen
das heißt wir haben später genug zeit
andere fragen andere probleme andere
sorgen zu klären denn sie bleiben noch
bei uns in der sendung sie sind heute
unser experte für die zuschauer fragen
und da gibt es definitiv einige dinge
über die wir sprechen müssen also bis
gleich ja es gibt nämlich schon große
probleme abzüglich des wissens dass die
bundesrepublik handlungsfähig ist
erstmal 470.000 betriebe nämlich also
fast eine halbe million die haben jetzt
schon kurzarbeit angemeldet was bedeutet
das für eine firma und für die
angestellten
hier einige beispiele aus baden
württemberg ja deutsche
automobilzulieferer sind probleme
gewöhnt aber wenn geschäftsführer markus
händler jetzt durch die werkshalle des
mittelständlers läuft reibt er sich
trotzdem die augen alle 600 mitarbeiter
in kurzarbeit geschickt die produktion
von sicherungs mutter auf 35 prozent
gedrosselt denn die autoproduktion in
deutschland steht still
eine krise in der form wie wir es jetzt
aktuell haben haben wir so noch nicht
erlebt da wo keine fahrzeuge produziert
werden
da wird natürlich auch keine
zubehörteile gebraucht das heißt wir
spüren es in unserem absatz ganz
deutlich der mittelständler stockt das
kurzarbeitergeld der regierung noch auf
die mitarbeiter bekommen bis zu 80
prozent ihres nettoeinkommens aber
trotzdem fürchten viele hier um ihre
zukunft natürlich ängste um ihren
arbeitsplatz weil sie wissen natürlich
nicht wie es weitergeht und wir wissen
dass leute mich nicht und man es trendig
bei der industrie und handelskammer
stuttgart stehen die telefone nicht
still
über 90 berater betreuen die hotline
meist im home-office die unsicherheit am
anderen ende der leitung ist mit händen
zu greifen wir finden dann bemühen
das ist wirklich schnell geht ja
soforthilfe kurzarbeitergeld verzweifelt
versuchen unternehmer sich über die
nächsten wochen zu retten
bei kleinen ist wirklich sehr bedrohlich
die haben häufig nicht viele rücklagen
haben einen totalausfall dadurch dass
die geschäfte geschlossen sind aber
dennoch viele verbindlichkeiten die
einfach gedeckt werden müssen in seinem
form von fixkosten von miete und aber
auch personalkosten wer kann sattelt um
wie der wäschehersteller mey auf der
schwäbischen alb unterwäsche und
badeanzüge verkaufen sich gerade nicht
also produziert das familienunternehmen
jetzt schutzmasken trotzdem ohne
kurzarbeitergeld wäre ihre existenz in
gefahr
die einzige chance die wir haben also
keinen umsatz nun
kosten laufen weiter andere größen
laufen weiter also es würde auch uns als
relativ gesundes unternehmen ganz
schnell vor
existenz kritische situationen bringen
auch den automobilzulieferer hewi rettet
das kurzarbeitergeld erstmal über die
nächsten wochen und dann wie groß der
wirtschaftliche schaden am ende sein
wird das kann noch niemand überblicken
und das genau diesen unsicherheiten und
auch ängsten aus genau denen wollen sich
andere bereichern online betrüger
nämlich für die bedeutet die korona
krise mit all ihren facetten und
auswirkungen ganz neue chancen sei es
wissen dass bank filialen geschlossen
sind und man über e mails kommuniziert
sei es durch gefälschte gesundheits
mails über die sie an passwörter wollen
oder weitere methoden die wir ihnen
jetzt verraten damit sie sich schützen
können cyberkriminelle sie sind schon in
normalen zeiten eine plage in zeiten der
krise aber umso mehr angst
verunsicherung isolation
sie sind der nährboden auf dem manch
übler betrug gedeiht generell
funktionieren betrugsdelikte vor krone
und auch jetzt in der korona krise immer
mit dem gleichen system mit das auslösen
von angst bei denen die man betrügen
möchte wird die risikoabwägung
herabgesetzt das heißt es wird stress
induziert und sind dann nicht mehr in
der lage ganz genau und nüchtern
abzuwägen wie denn das risikopotenzial
ist ein typisches beispiel nachrichten
in denen unter dem stichwort corona
neugier geweckt wird vorsicht gerät in
vergessenheit
also bekomme ich jetzt eine mail
vielleicht auch noch mit dem absender
von der bh oder von einem gesundheitsamt
dann würde ich also erst mal besonders
empfänglich und wenn mir der noch
angepriesen wird dass ich vielleicht die
neuesten infektionszahlen innerhalb
meiner nahen umgebung erhalten
dann bin ich vielleicht auch versucht so
ein link oder so eine anlage zu öffnen
merck aber nicht dass ich mir eine schad
software herunterladen und der täter
jetzt mit mir frei spieler andere
maschen kommen daher unter dem
deckmantel der wohltätigkeit einmal
verspricht der täter dem empfänger
riesige geldsummen denn er wolle als
glücklicher lotteriegewinner
der menschheit gutes tun man bräuchte
nur die bankverbindung oder jemand
bittet darum geld für den kampf gegen
korona zu spenden wenn die mail öffnet
weil er helfen will
tappt in die falle generell öffnet man
keine mails von unbekannten absendern
das ist ja gerade das hieße mit dem
tatmittel internet sie merken also nicht
mit der täter sie an die leine nimmt und
sie merken es auch nicht wenn er sie
wieder von der leine nimmt wichtig für
sie ist natürlich sie müssen sich
schützen dann natürlich auch müssen sie
ihren computer immer mit der aktuellen
software sage ich mal versorgen das gilt
nicht nur fürs virenschutzprogramm
sondern auch für die feier bolt und so
präsent liche software diese auf ihrem
rechner haben denn über nichts freut
sich der täter mehr als veraltete
software die auf ihrem rechner vorfindet
zur gefahr werden jetzt auch
internetseiten die eigentlich
ausverkaufte waren wie schutzmasken oder
desinfektionsmittel anbieten
wo gibt es die chance das begehrte gut
noch zu erwerben wer ist ein betrüger
ein paar einfache anhaltspunkte helfen
das erste anzeichen ist dass man halt
ein impressum nicht findet vielleicht
findet man auch keine agb auf der
internetseite und häufig ist der preis
dermaßen niedrig dass man halt gelockt
wird auf dieser seite zu kaufen und zum
anderen kann man natürlich auch die
firma selber mal googeln und gucken ob
das schon bewertungen gibt ob andere
nutzer und käufer sich über die firma
vielleicht im internet schon beschwert
haben denn ist die rechnung erst einmal
bezahlt gibt es kein geld zurück
die anbieter sitzen dann sehr häufig im
ausland und man soll dann auch das geld
ins ausland überweisen wenn man das tut
bekommt man natürlich keine ware sondern
das geld ist weg
der sicherste zahlungsweg nur wenn man
waren und im internet bestellt ist
natürlich wenn man sich die waren auf
rechnung liefern lässt
so ist man also seid ihr immer auf der
sicheren seite man hat nämlich einmal
die ware schon empfangen und kann jetzt
beurteilen über nämlich sie oder nicht
oder wenn ich die ware nicht bekomme ich
bezahle ich auch nicht die rechnung
anzeige wegen betrug kann man stellen
klar aber die polizei ist halt nicht ein
ein helfer und dafür das geld zurück zu
bekommen sondern das muss man selber
machen meinem anwalt über die gerichte
die beziehung zur hausbank in normalen
zeiten vertrauensvoll und unkompliziert
jetzt muss auch hier vorsicht walten
stichwort daten klauen
im fall der banken ist es so und wir
haben das auch schon bemerkt dass der
täter vor gibt ja viele filialen
schließen wir wollen aber mit dir als
kunden enger noch in kontakt bleiben
also bieten wir jetzt auch an online dir
zu sprechen
dafür brauchen wir dann den neuesten
informationen zunächst erst mal wichtig
zu wissen dass die meisten dieser
betrüger auf einer rhetorischen ebene
also in der direkten form der ansprache
relativ gut ausgebildet sind das heißt
sie finden in den ersten worten und
sätzen eine möglichkeit kontakt
anzubahnen oder dem kunden wird geraten
angesichts abstürzender börsenkurse geld
und aktien in sicherheit zu bringen
auch dazu bräuchte man die aktuellen
kontodaten wer das glaubt verliert alles
bevor ich also irgendwo drauf klicken
mache ich mich doch mal schlau wenn ich
das gefühl habe ich bei meiner bank an
und frage ist denn diese mail eigentlich
autorisiert von euch worden sind und man
befürchten muss dass unter umständen die
bank daten abhanden gekommen sind sollte
man sofort alle daten wo es noch
irgendwie möglich ist zu ändern und
natürlich vorsichtshalber auch dann
beispielsweise die bankverbindung die
kreditkarte sperren zu lassen und dann
informiert man am besten polizei und
verbraucherzentrale
wir können informieren und warnen und
auf diese weise andere vor den fiesen
tricks der internetbetrüger schützen
jetzt zum start in den neuen monat
werden sie wieder völlig millionen
mieten müssen gezahlt werden in
deutschland aber durch die auswirkungen
der krise wird das für viele zunehmend
zu einem problem
was kann man tun wenn das geld knapp
wird für die nächste miete china im
home-office seit einer woche nicht mehr
im büro ab april ist die 28-jährige in
kurzarbeit noch unklar wie groß ihre
einbußen dann sind das corona virus
stellt leben auf den kopf und bringt
existenzen ins überlegen ich habe meiner
rechnung zu bezahlen dass ich erst mal
schauen was habe ich für fixkosten im
monat wo kann ich vielleicht darum
bitten verträge auszusetzen und ja auch
die miete ist natürlich ein hoher anteil
weil es macht fast ein drittel des
nettoeinkommens aus sie ist mit ihrem
vermieter im gespräch bisher sperrt er
sich aber noch gegen ratenzahlungen
immerhin sollte sich ihre situation
zuspitzen kann sie noch mal nachfragen
selbst den vermieter zu kontaktieren sei
aber die richtige strategie sagt der
mieterbund sehr wichtig ist dass mieter
die absehen können dass sie in
finanzielle bedrängnis geraten nicht
erst warten bis die zweite miete fällig
ist sondern dass man früh das gespräch
sucht mit dem vermieter die meisten
vermieter sind anständige leute sie
haben verständnis
es hilft nichts den kopf in den sand zu
stecken
davon geht das nicht weg allerdings will
der mieterbund mehr als nur den
kündigungsschutz vom bund denn
aufgeschoben ist nicht aufgehoben die
mieten müssen ja nachgezahlt werden ein
staatsfonds müsse her
es sollte ein fonds geschaffen werden
aus dem heraus
rückständige mieten bezahlt werden
können
denn wenn mieten auflaufen dann ist ja
demjenigen der ohnehin am ende
sala finanzkraft ist auch nicht damit
geholfen wenn er dann mit schulden
herumläuft
auch die vermieter spüren den crooner
druck denn auch gewerbetreibende ohne
einnahmen fragen nach aufschub für
manche vermieter nicht einfach einige
werden das so ohne weiteres nicht
hinbekommen wir werden das nicht
finanziell stemmen können jetzt einfach
auf die mietzahlung zu verzichten
denn es laufen natürlich weiter
finanzierungen es gibt aber auch
insbesondere die älteren vermieter und
wenn man natürlich dann sich auch mal
die zahlen anschaut dass 40 prozent der
privaten vermieter 60 jahre alt und
älter sind dann ist das im grunde
letztendlich dann auch für die rente für
die aufstockung der rente aber auch für
den lebensunterhalt sehr sehr wichtig
und den lebensunterhalt muss auch china
für sich bestreiten können wie geht sie
mit der krise um ein paar hundert euro
werde er wohl bald fehlen wenn ich mir
gedanken über die nächsten monate mache
mit der korona krise ist ganz klar an
erster stelle ich muss meine fixkosten
decken auch mit weniger geld und dann
hoffe ich aber dass wir in drei vier
vielleicht auch fünf monaten wieder alle
mehr oder weniger in die normalität
zurück gehen können und ich dann
natürlich auch wieder vollgas geben kann
in der firma immerhin konnte sie die
verträge fürs fitnessstudio und für die
auto- raten unterbrechen
und sie hofft dass das auch bei der
miete so sein wird wenn ihr geld dafür
fehlen sollte
und für genau diese jetzt auftauchenden
problemen und fragen haben wir den
experten hermann josef tenhagen nämlich
den chefredakteur von finanztest haben
wieder eine menge fragen erreicht per
melden und die erste defizit sich direkt
auf das thema wohnen und die damit
zusammenhängenden kosten was wir gerade
gesehen haben simone galliano die fragt
ich habe ein haus gekauften zahle
kredite ab bei kurzarbeit könnte ich
diese nicht mehr bedienen muss ich angst
haben vor einer zwangsversteigerung und
wo bekomme ich die hilfe das ist die
frage
also das wichtigste ist erst mal dass
sie tatsächlich mit dem mit der bank
reden darüber dass sie die kredite
strecken können viele von den
kreditverträgen die man da hat lassen
das zu dass man dinge streckt dass man
zum beispiel keine tilgung macht mit
zeitlang oder dass man eben auch fahrten
nach hinten schiebt mit der bank reden
das sollte gegen die bank hatte
überhaupt kein interesse daran einen
solchen kredit vertrag gerade wenn er
jung ist irgendwie zu beenden das ist
für die bank auch ein riesenschaden von
daher gehen sie hin und besprechen sie
dass das kriegen sie hin kriegen sehen
sehr gut aus sagen wir hören das öfter
in diesen tagen sprechen hilft
vielleicht auch bei der frage von r
punkt herrmann
wie wirkt sich eine längere kurzarbeit
aus verursacht durch das bewohner virus
und zwar auf die spätere rente
tatsächlich ist es so wenn sie jetzt 100
prozent kurzarbeit hätten also überhaupt
nicht mehr arbeiten würden dann würden
sie über das kurzarbeitergeld und über
die regelungen dafür 80 prozent ihres
früheren einkommens weiter
rentenbeiträge einzahlen das heißt sie
haben die absicherung der
rentenversicherung und sie haben ein
bisschen weniger rente wenn man das
jetzt mal für einen
durchschnittsverdiener macht dann ist
das wenn das ganze jahr in kurzarbeit
wäre würden das vielleicht sieben oder
acht euro weniger rente sein später das
klingt nach der warnung auf jeden fall
erstmal nicht so dramatisch wie man es
liest michael botzenhart hat uns
geschrieben er möchte wissen ob die
banken bei privatkunden während der
kubakrise überziehungszinsen verlangen
können beim girokonto ja wenn wenn sie
jenseits des displays sind dann können
die auch weiter höhere
überziehungszinsen verlangen das tun
aber nicht alle also die frankfurter
sparkasse zum beispiel gesagt sie hat
den dispo-zins in diesem bereich
halbiert auf 499 das tun aber wiederum
auch nicht alle banken also da versuchen
möglichst nicht im dispo zu sein weil
tatsächlich könnte die bank den dispo
den ich habe reduzieren und dann muss
ich sogar noch mehr zinsen bezahlen
versuchen sie das da rauszukommen nicht
im dispo zu sein
andere regelungen es gibt rahmenkredite
für viele dahin zu gehen wenn das nicht
geht müssen sie einfach schauen dass sie
die ausgaben runter bekommen und
sprechen sie auch mit der bank weil
sozusagen wenn sie nicht bezahlen können
zb ein ratenkredit oder so dann müssen
sie den ratenkredit ja können sie auch
für drei monate stunden also nicht
bezahlen und wenn sie sich mit der band
nicht einigen können geht der
ratenkredit einfach nach ganz hinten
also sozusagen sie bezahlen den an den
fünf jahren am ende ihres ratenkredit
und alle wissen im moment worum es geht
von daher ist hoffentlich die
bereitschaft auch
größer und groß entgegenzukommen
christiane an opel hat gemailt und sie
vermietet eine wohnung und auch ein
gewerbegebäude also jetzt diese andere
seite als eben beitrag muss selber
kredite zahlen wird mir auch geholfen
als kleinvermieter wenn mieter mir eben
nicht mehr zahlen das ist die andere
seite
das ist genau die andere seite und an
der seite ist man schon tatsächlich
schon wieder bei der bank natürlich und
muss mit denen darüber reden wie das
weiter funktionieren kann wie man seine
raten zum teil stunden kann weil bisher
ist es so dass das nur für klassische
verbraucherkredite diese raten sozusagen
nach hinten geschoben werden können der
gesetzgeber hat sich aber gleich ein
hintertürchen offen gelassen und hat
gesagt diese die frage bei welchen
krediten man das alles machen kann
die könnte man einfach per verordnung
auch erweitern und zum beispiel auch
diese immobilienkredite da einbeziehen
also viel informationen viele antworten
und ein großer dank an sie
hermann josef tenhagen für die antworten
der korona kompakt bereiten wir täglich
neu und aktuell vor und liefern ihnen
dann auch das ganze jederzeit über
youtube nach hause
sie finden es dort über den kanal der
zdf- heute -nachrichten und für die
morgige ausgabe
da haben wir einen virologen eingeladen
der dann auch ihre fragen beantwortet
also wenn sie wissen möchten einfach
eine mail corinna kompakte zdf de
vielleicht gibt es dann hier direkt im
studio die antwort